this is a advice to my beloved sisters
Mela bless you all about if you are
married alhamdulillah and you have a
husband that is taking care of you uh
even if he falls into shortcomings be
patient you know and be respectful to
your husband because I've seen many
videos people advising Brothers to take
care of their wives and so on but
likewise we have to give a reminder to
sisters to be patient with their
husbands to take care of their husbands
to respect their husbands and to not
rush into divorce you know subhanallah
how many sisters divorced the husbands
or ask for divorce from their husbands
afterwards they regretted it and they
really want when they go March someone
else they remember the virtues of the
ex-husband so take care of your husband
may Allah bless you all look after him
treat him with respect and be patient
with him especially that some were
living in the some will live in Illinois
is a time of fitting tries and
tribulations and read the biographies of
the companions females
audio patient and their obedience to
their husbands may Allah bless you all